beat the Sun up folks you got to beat
the Sun up if you can't beat up the
roll-up of the Sun up you're gonna get
beat up in life okay I've been doing
this for a long time now I'd say beat
That Thing Up that monster out there
that warms this planet that nourishes
and gives us light you can't live it to
next life if you're not beating the Sun
up so many of you complaining about how
much time you have you don't have time
man because you don't beat the Sun up
get started early and when you get
started early that means you need to
shut it down early I was asleep last
night at nine o'clock so I could beat
the sun up to mark this morning and see
the world wake up with me hey seven
Carmichael and I make these videos
because running the business is hard and
waking up every day and getting to work
when you're all by yourself is hard and
the thing that saved me that continues
to inspire me motivate me give me hope
inspiration ideas is looking at the
stories of people who've done a lot more
than me and I learned strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack day and so I
hope this video inspires you to do the
same as well so today let's learn the 10
simple habits that will dramatically
improve your life enjoy
what does a morning look like for you at
the moment if you've got a routine of
some kind yes I run every single morning
so that's time you up when you're waking
up up about 5 5 30. so every morning it
starts with the Run
and that's because that's the one thing
I hate to do more than anything in the
world
so that's like my cup of coffee
and I'm all about armoring yourself
so the second you leave your house
and you second you open your phone the
second you do any of that you are now
letting in poison in cancer
so I make sure a lot of things you can't
avoid
so as I get up I start to armor plate my
mind and body like a person's going to
war you put your body armor on that's
what I'm doing on that run
I'm waking up and I'm giving myself all
this armor so when I come out in the
world now look at that phone I'm ready
I'm not waking up late I'm not rushing
around I'm not disorganized because I
know I'm gonna get hit in the mouth
there's a there's an art to getting hit
in the mouth
and that is why these things are
important you have to wake up and you
have to give yourself belief you have to
give yourself confidence that it starts
with that run there is one habit that I
have adopted in the last three years
that has fundamentally changed me as a
business person and it has also changed
my ability to manage my emotions so I
don't get hijacked I do not allow my
phone in the bedrooms
I know the research
Deloitte just did a study based on phone
use alone and 33 percent of people are
reading emails in the middle of the
night I know that if you go to bed and
the phone is right next to you right so
you go to bed because you need your
phone you know somebody might need you
and you sleep
you know if this is right here and it's
not closed and the blue light is on
they've done studies where you have
people at a table and the researcher
will put their phone on the table not
even my phone the researcher's phone and
the Brain lights up like crazy just with
the presence of a phone the research
around the phone and sleep is so
stunning that if you were to adopt one
radical thing today other than the five
second rule try putting your phone
outside your bedroom turn off
so you don't hear it tell people who
need to reach you to call you my kids I
have a kid in college a kid who's you
know high school kid in middle school if
there's an emergency call me
there is nothing happening on your phone
at two o'clock in the morning that's
important but if you allow yourself to
become a tool of this this is supposed
to be your tool for selling your tool
for communicating and we're all becoming
the tool here's the other thing Common
Sense wise that I want you to understand
you wake up
the alarm goes off
what do you do
so you're not even vertical and you're
reading emails
and what is in these emails other
people's crap if you don't have
boundaries with this puppy
it's going to impact sleep it's going to
impact how much money you make it's
going to impact how much self-control
you have and so when I put this thing
outside the bedroom and I wake up I walk
over to where the phone is it's plugged
into my bathroom I turn it off I don't
look at it yet I give myself five
minutes five minutes before I tune into
the world to actually tune in up here
and say what's the one thing I'm going
to get done today that really matters to
me if you're the kind of person that
feels like you don't have control over
your day that your day gets hijacked
that you can't get to the priorities
that you're always behind the ball this
one planning thing will change your life
no phone in the bedroom turn it off when
the alarm goes off five minutes five
lousy minutes five lousy minutes before
you tune into the rest of the world and
if you've got the kind of job where
you've got to check it get up 10 minutes
earlier
you have control over this stuff and it
is so important that you take it
seriously now because you're living at
the slowest moment of your entire life
take a cold shower
we're doing all of this to accomplish
two goals
toughen up buttercup
and cognitively optimize so working out
as much as it's good for the brain it's
also to show you that you can do hard
things because in your life you need to
be doing hard things the other hard
thing you're going to do that's also
good for your brain and good for a whole
host of other things including
anti-inflammatory
um getting uh all the effects of
longevity that come from cold exposure
you're going to get in a cold shower now
the amount of time you need to stay in
the cold shower is going to depend on
the time of year and where you live
because let me tell you Minnesota in
February is very different than La in
August the cold temperature in La in
August not that cold so and compared to
and I've actually done this was it in
Minnesota no Chicago I did Chicago in
the winter I can't remember exactly what
month and the water hitting my forehead
gave me a headache I was like damn this
is a whole nother level of cold so doing
that versus in La was a world of
difference but in La I would keep myself
in the shower I think my record was like
oh God it was somewhere between 12 and
17 minutes I can't remember but for uh
what was it 13 months I did this every
single shower weekend no weekend
actually that might be a lie every
shower Monday through Friday that's
correct I think on the weekends I
allowed myself a warm shower don't hold
me to that I can't remember but for 13
months I took so many cold showers it
was horrifying in fact I stopped I
promised myself I'd do it for 30 days I
did it for 13 months I began to resent
my shower
but it is extremely powerful for doing
things that are difficult so we're gonna
do the cold challenge expose yourself
for the cold as long as you can possibly
bear extend that period of time you
should be shivering before you get out
of the shower like uncontrollably
shivering that is a good way of knowing
if you've been in long enough also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there social media getting dopamine hit
after dopamine hit
when we first get on social media after
a while for the first time or after a
long period of time the amount of
dopamine that's released we think is
quite substantial it's novel remember
dopamine is about novelty surprise and
the sense that we are on some exciting
track that's what dopamine is really
about it puts us into states of
Readiness anticipation looking seeking
Etc almost always for things outside the
confines of our skin just to contrast it
maybe for a bit more of a future
discussion
serotonin does the opposite when there's
a lot of serotonin in our brain and body
typically it makes us feel satisfied
saded and more quiet and comfortable
with what we have in our own immediate
sphere and within us right the comfort
of a good meal the food you have
dopamine is about go go if you look at
somebody who's high on cocaine or
Methamphetamine it's all about Pursuit
because that's a very dopaminergic drug
you look at somebody who's taking a drug
and I'm not suggesting people do this
but it really ramps up serotonin let's
say a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor Prozac Zoloft Etc the side
effects of those drugs if the dosages
are too high lack of appetite lack of
libido kind of meh about life you know
then so they'll adjust the dose down
that's because those are serotonergic
drugs so
in in general
when we are in pursuit of things
dopamine is is quite high so now you
have to remind me your question because
I've set up the dopamine serotonin uh
cell phones uh cell phones yes
um forgive me so
the thing about cell phones is when you
first get on there and you haven't let's
say you're no Wi-Fi on the flight or
something and you land it can actually
be quite stimulating you get a lot of
dopamine oh there's this oh there's that
but very quickly when you're scrolling
on social media
you're no longer getting the novelty but
you're continuing to do it you almost
don't know why you're doing it at that
point it shifts over to something that's
a bit more like an obsessive compulsive
Behavior where that we can define an
obsessive-compulsive Behavior where the
obsession leads to a compulsion so the
obsession is a thought that compulsion
is a behavior but the acting out of the
compulsion merely serves to increase the
obsession right this is very different
than being obsessed with food or
obsessed with cleanliness there's no
payoff right exactly there's no Anxiety
Relief by carrying out the compulsion
with OCD behaviors
like scrolling social media the dopamine
quickly wanes and then you find that
you're just so and we've all been there
you're scrolling you're like why am I
doing this this isn't that interesting
that is this isn't that interesting now
the algorithms for social media are very
clever and I don't want to demonize it I
you know provide a lot of a lot of my
life has spent on you know on social
media now but
in the algorithms that they've
Incorporated function on the the most
powerful way to keep people doing a
behavior or an animal for that matter is
intermittent random reward a random
intermittent reward that you don't know
when you're going to hit the jackpot so
you're scrolling you're scrolling and
then you see something typically it's
very high what you know in nerd speak
we'd say signal to noise so if you're
reading some interesting things this
came out in the news this came out and
then it's all of a sudden a riot or a
person that is Jump is base jumping off
a building or
um you know for people that are are
scrolling looking at bodies or something
like that live bodies that hopefully
people aren't looking at the dead bodies
but look if something's very tragic then
that has this gravitational pull and
then you what happens is you start
getting
the system working for that next
dopamine hit that you don't know when
it's going to come it's just like
gambling so I look at social media as
initially being very dopaminergic
driving rewards surprised and excitement
but very quickly transitioning to
something more like OCD and the kinds of
behaviors where it looks if you if we
were to look at ourselves through the
lens of an experiment like we would an
animal experiment we think that animal
is sick if you saw an animal digging in
the corner looking looking looking
looking looking for a bone the dog is
looking looking looking looking looking
you'd think that's really sad that's us
right that's us I'm pointing myself
intentionally that's us so we have to
learn to self-regulate the amount of
time but that doesn't have to be a
process of you know scruffing ourselves
and saying don't do it don't do it think
about it in terms of the positive the
more time away from something the more
positively reinforcing it will be when
you return every morning in Seal
training my instructors who at the time
were all Vietnam veterans
would show up in my Barracks room
and the first thing they do is inspect
my bed if you did it right
the corners would be square the covers
would be pulled tight the pillow
centered just under the headboard and
the extra blanket folded neatly at the
foot of the rack
it was a simple task
mundane at best but every morning we
were required to make our bed to
perfection
that seemed a little ridiculous at the
time particularly in light of the fact
that we were aspiring to be real
Warriors tough battle-hardened seals
but the wisdom of this simple act has
been proven to me many times over
if you made your bed every morning
you will have accomplished the first
task of the day
it will give you a small sense of pride
and it will encourage you to do another
task and another and another
and by the end of the day that one task
completed will have turned into many
tasks completed making your bed will
also reinforce the fact
that the little things in life matter
if you can't do the little things right
you'll never be able to do the big
things right
and if by chance you have a miserable
day
you will come home to a bed that is made
that you made
and a maid bed gives you encouragement
that tomorrow will be better
so if you want to change the world
start off by making your bed I've
achieved some pretty good goals in my
life and my entire you know life from 19
to 61 a lot of years right involved
setting goals and getting precise on you
know what I want to achieve when do I
want to achieve it by how am I going to
achieve it one of the skills necessary
to achieve it Etc so these are some of
the things I know you're already aware
of
and one of the things that I wish I did
more of
was review like review where was I you
know on the path to achieving those
goals so I set the goals that I
developed the strategies for them and I
didn't do enough reviews on a weekly
basis so for example now
I review my goals every day
I review my results every week I review
my results and my plans every month
every quarter and I take time
to think
plan do and review let me repeat that I
take time to think
then plan than to do and review and I
keep repeating that process over and
over again I just went to India to get
certified to be a meditation instructor
went through a two-week process and it's
something I try to do on a daily basis
and when I Implement a daily meditation
practice I feel it I feel positive I
feel clear I feel intentional about what
I'm doing I'm less reactive since I've
been back there have been days I've
missed doing my meditation and since
missing them I feel lethargic I feel
lazier I feel more reactive or
frustrated in certain times so I
definitely feel the difference from the
days I meditate versus the days I don't
so set yourself up to win in this year
to making your greatest year ever by
having a daily meditation practice I'm
telling you guys it's so simple
meditation is becoming well known from
people all over the world now it's not
some weird thing anymore people are
talking about it in the workforce in
sports in relationships whatever it may
be it's all good and set yourself up to
win we're talking about journaling
writing things down or should I say
capturing your ideas and your intentions
now
when I look at my own practices they've
evolved over the years I think I
probably have enough journals over the
last 25 years to fill up at least
someone's home Library
in my journals I jot down what I'm
thinking I jot down how I'm feeling I
jot down random ideas I jot down God's
downloads to me
I don't have a particular rigid order to
my journals
because my journals is where my
creativity flows
but in the last five years my journaling
has evolved I actually write a lot less
and now
I have an audio Journal so I have a file
of my thoughts because I actually like
to not only know what I'm thinking but
I'd like to feel the tone now I like to
feel the energy now of my thoughts and
so I audio Journal a lot
I audio Journal when I'm on the plane
I auto journal in the airport I don't
care about the background noise
I wake up at night grab my phone and I
audio record because there's so many
ways that you can Auto record I ought to
record my thoughts
is it important to write down your
thoughts and your practices I think so
is it important to Capture Moments in
your life and where they are
when my students first step on my campus
I say take a picture of your life I
don't mean to physically take a picture
of your life don't take a picture of
your front door a picture of your
kitchen shut down where your
relationship is jot down what feels good
about it and jot down what's
uncomfortable about it jot down your
belief systems what excites you and what
has you afraid jot down your health
what status is it in
what are your goals there what are your
pain points there jot it all down not
just the intentions and goals but jot
down frustrations and tolerations why
you want to capture your frustrations
and tolerations because when you're in
Personal Mastery like this when you're
in human potential development when
you're working on yourself those
tolerations and pain points won't always
be there
and you want to remember
you want to remember the progress that
you made most of us will not grow in 180
degrees form we'll grow need a point
move by needlepoint move
by needlepoint move
and so
journaling is important
it may not look like anyone else's form
of journaling and that's okay
but take a picture of your life
then take a snapshot of your ideas
Auto record your dreams
ought to record that thing you're not
even ready to take action on so it'll be
there when you're ready
or at least you'll remember to be
creative
prayerful acknowledging grateful
so remember journaling
is based on you
no one else's journey is like yours
so no one else's Journal will be like
yours as well
happy capturing a lot of interaction
with a guy around gratitude and it was
just like very interesting I was just
like yeah once you go there you really
actually don't need anything else the
Simplicity of the Gratitude framework
like if you're just actually grateful
for what you have actually for the
littlest things versus envious for the
that you don't have everything's
just better every single problem you
have gets better even the most extreme
things like are you grateful for the
time you had with somebody you loved you
know that kind of gratitude wins
I feel like there's like a stepping
stone or something bad or pivotal number
no I think it was just a I listen to
positive people around me I just limited
envy and jealousy and I leaned into
optimism and gratitude and I'd been
practicing it for 40 years and here I am
humans are byproducts of the information
and the energy they decide to consume
this is why I would get so crazy just
about like people who want to like stay
in unhappiness if you're deeply unhappy
instead of blaming everyone else for it
put in the work to get out of it because
you can I believe in people I believe in
you like you can do it one can create
their luck by acknowledging right in
this minute as you watch this video or
listen to it on podcast that you're like
yeah everyone has a moment
that lady just now earlier just before
like I quit my job to start my own
agency
and you were like just do all the
content
thank you I'm proud of you thank you
I was there like I just heard you say it
do it and I was like it was my that that
was my time and we're all affected by
that I'm just one human there's lots of
people doing different versions of this
if you want to find positivity it's
everywhere there's just way too much
momentum right now of people looking for
a negativity what they're doing is
they're avoiding accountability it gets
really cozy to blame Perfection for not
doing oh you don't get it Julian I'm a
perfectionist that's why I can't put out
this video I'm a perfectionist no you're
not you're cute with your words and
you're using as an excuse to not do
because you fear failure you're not a
perfectionist you're of an avoider
people just decided that everyone else's
life is perfect like you have no idea
what's going on in someone's head or
there are four walls behind their door
it's just not true all that energy to
judge others for their perfection or
what they did wrong it's all outward
what about putting it on yourself
your environment is keeping you where
you are your environment has been
perfectly designed to keep you exactly
where you are right now the people you
listen to the media that you consume the
habits that you do daily all of them all
of them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment I've
changed a lot over the course of having
this YouTube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years I've said Edwin you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more Poise
you're a better speaker you you're
pushing the boundaries more you've
changed what happened how do I get that
for myself right people wanted it
whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving other people they
want it they want a taste of it they
want to do it too because we are not
designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over and over again so how did
I get it I've paid more attention to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with it's
important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
that the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment
you need to change it because everything
you're doing right now is keeping you on
the path that you're on maybe there's
been some growth if you look at who you
were five years ago compared to now
you've grown if you're watching this
channel you've grown right you've made
some changes but is it drastic enough
like are you proud of where you're at
look at where you've come from in the
past year two years five years are you
proud of where you're at and are you
comfortable with that same level of
growth for the next five years if not if
you think I want more I want to help
faster I want to have a bigger impact
faster quicker then the fastest way to
do it is to change your environment so
that's you I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is cut out
negativity just cut out the people who
don't serve you sometimes those are
friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university
you're in the Friendship out of
convenience now there's a lot of people
who you might need to let go of you
might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've you've
walked your parallel path together and
now they've gone out well they've
probably just stayed here while you've
gone out here
They don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that that becomes
toxic even if you're trying to be a
beacon even if you're trying to be the
person who pulls everybody up
if all you're doing is trying to pull
other people up and there's nothing
pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the fire walk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed this skin so that I can be
reborn like there's this new skin none
of you that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should a less drastic version of that is
just don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
see I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life step number two is then
seek out optimism seek out positivity
seek out things that make you grow that
make you want to learn that make you
want to push yourself right I have my
channel that's really helped me that
every day I wake up and I'm surrounded
by positivity and optimism and belief
and things that drive me forward that
even if I've I've had a rough sleep or a
bad day or or whatever it might be I see
Steve Jobs right next to me staring me
down I have my parents behind me looking
at me encouraging me putting belief back
in me I've got videos to go to that will
build me up I've got my believe playlist
of music that I listen to that will
change my state and bring me back to a
place of optimism positivity what is it
for you
is it people do you need to be around
people physically can you go to meetup
groups can you go to the library or
coffee shop can you go join some
entrepreneur circles can you become part
of a co-working place can you be around
people
that that are positive that are
energizing for you or can it be your
physical environment right or can it be
your habits and your routines or can it
be the the media you consume what are
you consuming what are you watching on
TV
or on Netflix is it is it entertainment
are you just shutting off your life to
try to forget about your problems and
just be entertained or you're trying to
educate yourself to build a better life
this is this is one of the fundamental
problems in the world right now
people they have problems you have
problems most people choose
entertainment as a way to forget about
their problems instead of Education as a
way to make their problems better do you
want to shut off the world
and and laugh at somebody else's expense
and watch big brother and see man that
person's life sucks
or you want to go build a better life
for yourself
most people don't want to do the work to
actually build a better life I hope that
you do because that's how you actually
end up being happy if you want to numb
it with drugs do you actually want to
build a better life for yourself and in
Step number three is scheduled for
success
schedule for Success so what are your
daily habits what's in your calendar
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold alive contagious you know optimism
what's the thing for me it's watching
videos for me it's going through my 5S
schedule so I start the day with singing
where I have videos that are on YouTube
that just their songs that make me want
to sing make me want to dance make me
want to move it's the fastest way to
change your state I wake up tired and
maybe low energy and then I put on music
and it and it changes my state and makes
me happy do that for yourself don't put
on music that matches your current mood
put on music that matches the mood that
you want to feel like it's the fastest
way to just in a snap be able to change
yourself we all have music that makes
you bounce and come alive start your day
with that right that's part of mine so
singing then Sun I like getting Sun uh
going outside being in nature just
having sun on my face not just being
stuck inside all day especially in the
morning makes a big difference my third
s is sore so I want to do something
makes me feel bold and come alive and
for me I love my phone here but for me I
share a message I want to share a
message you want to feel like the work
that I do has meaning and importance so
I think about somebody that I helped
yesterday and then I share a message on
Instagram and Snapchat and put it up
that helps me soar what do you need for
yourself then I sweat so I'll do a quick
workout and then I do something to scare
myself right now it's doing
um cold shower so I sweat and then I
take a cold shower and it's like and I
do difficult things that's my morning
routine right I called the five five and
a half s rule because
some days I'll start with a snuggle with
my wife in bed so we're seeing if that's
going to become like a 6S protocol but
at least it's five and a half right now
that's what makes me come alive
we might need something totally
different I'm okay with that that's
amazing maybe you need to meditate maybe
you need to pray maybe you need to pet
your cat what is the thing that you need
to do to make you feel bold and alive
and and then schedule that in so that
you're not hoping one day that something
happens you're not hoping that you're
gonna meet the right person or hoping
you're gonna find the right video like
demand Excellence from yourself demand
positivity and optimism from yourself
every day because if you did if you were
bold coffin optimistic positive every
morning if you created that system for
yourself man what could you accomplish
in a year can you imagine
if you did something every morning that
made you feel bold and confident if you
felt bold and confident every morning
for the next year imagine the life and
business that you're gonna have it's
crazy it's wild right so you have to
create that you have to schedule for
success success will come from your
habits so look at your calendar what are
your habits and if you did these habits
would it lead to you becoming a success
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to develop
any habit with ease with James Clear
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there and the question
is can you take control of the process I
think that the more sustainable strategy
the more reliable strategy is to scale
it down to the first two minutes focus
on that establish it Master the art of
showing up